- [Cece] Hi Gary, I'm so excited.
- Hello, not that I'm right.
- Come on in!
- Thank you.
- Yes.
- How are you?
- They're getting you your latte.
I'm Cece, I'm the one who's
been talking with Maddie.
- [Gary] Thank you, thank you so much.
- [Cece] Of course.
Can Erica take a picture
with you real quick?
- Sure.
Hi Erica, how are you,
thank you, thank you.
- You're, thank you, it means a lot.
- Awesome.
- Thank you, I love all your videos.
- Thank you, thank you, thank you so much.
- Thank you, she's the sweetest too.
(Cece laughs)
- Hey guy.
- Nice to see you, bro.
- Mario, our digital,
he's gonna be filming you.
- Mario, real pleasure,
thank you for having me.
- Great to meet you, Mario,
great to meet you too.
- And then uh that's a snake?
Snakes, I don't like snakes.
I don't like them.
(Gary taps glass)
(Gary laughs)
- Shout out to your fucking team, bro.
- [Gary] Thank you, my guy.
- You guys capture like
the sickest shit, man.
Like whether it's on the
scene, behind the scenes
- Thank you so much.
- He doesn't even know
they're rolling right now.
- I appreciate it, thank
you so much, my guy.
- [Mario] Good shit, man.
- Thank you, what's up, man?
- [Cece] Big fan too?
- How you doing--
- Real pleasure,
thank you, my man.
- Isn't it crazy like everyone
that works at Power and here
is like a huge fan of
yours, everybody follows
We had our huge programming meeting
and we reminded people you were coming
and everybody was so excited.
Everybody was like,
"Oh my god, I'm following
him, I follow him."
- [Gary] Thank you.
- So it's cool because
they're genuine fans
and they genuinely follow you.
- [Gary] Thank you, thank you so much.
- Yeah, absolutely.
- [Gary] Super excited to be here.
What's up, man, thank you so much.
- Camera man, got you.
- Such a pleasure.
- Such a pleasure
to meet you in person man.
- Thank you so much.
- It really really is, dude.
Thank you for coming through, man.
You got a lot of words of wisdom.
- Thank you, my guy.
- I'm excited you're sharing
them with our audience.
- I can't wait, I really can't.
- It's gonna be a lot of fun.
- [Cece] And Maddie asked
if it was approved for live
or if it was gonna be recorded.
- We're gonna do pre-recorded.
- Awesome, yeah.
- That way you can let
all the bad words fly
and have no pressure on you.
For real, because I've seen you
and you let it go, man.
- [Cece] As you should.
- When I do TV and live, I never, I never.
I'm always respectful.
Excuse me, what up, my guy?
Scientists have decided a
mind-controlling parasite
found in a cat's face that may give people
the courage they need
to become entrepreneurs.
(laughing)
- That's when you know--
- I had no idea that
my life would come down
to me competing with a
mind-controlling parasite
found in the face of a fucking cat.
(group laughs)
- Dang.
- It's me versus the
mind-controlling parasites.
- Cruz, great to see you.
- Cruz, my guy, how are you?
- [Cruz] It's a pleasure, man.
- So glad we're doing this.
- Thank you for your time,
thank you for your energy.
- For real.
- I promise we will not
fucking bullshit you.
- I'm not scared of anything.
- No no no no.
- I'm ready.
- You're valued here
so know that going in.
- No, I appreciate that, I feel that,
I feel that, thank you.
- My guy, you need anything?
Sorry we're under
construction so you know.
- Dude, I come from the
dirt, this is fancy.
- I love that, I love that.
Alright, you guys need anything, guys?
- No, we're good.
- Nope, nope.
What's that?
Yeah it's funny, I think.
That's such a good point, DRock.
I think exposed is the best word.
Right, you've been exposed, it's so funny.
I, you know what, I do that
a lot actually I've realized.
I've had to start hedging
a little bit in some quotes
where I'm like, I don't know like
where I use a negative word as a positive.
I do that a lot.
Damage, I use damage.
We're gonna do a ton of damage here.
And it was like--
- Or god forbid.
- Or God forbid I use as a good thing.
God forbid we fucking get a hit song
and everyone's so, I do that a ton
and it's actually probably
very interesting insight.
DRock, this is a good time
to create some clarity.
- [DRock] What?
- You know I said if you
drink $6 coffee, you're soft.
You know if you ever bought
a $5 Starbucks coffee,
you're fucking soft.
If you ever in your life
bought a $5 fucking coffee
from Starbucks, you are fucking soft.
Globally, in the 7.7 billion
people, you're fucking fancy.
You're soft, a $5 fucking
cup of coffee, fuck you.
I'm drinking a $7 coffee because it's Ty.
If you're complaining like
oh I don't have any money
or I can't start my business
but you're buying $6 coffee,
you're soft, if you're not complaining,
whether you're 40,000
bucks or 40 million bucks,
then drink $8 coffee, I don't give a fuck.
This whole fucking system is
predicated on complaining.
You happy, don't listen to me, right?
- Right!
(cheering)
- Yo yo yo yo yo yo yo, hello!
Oh that's a lot of
fucking energy, let's go!
But there's so many people
I know that make 40,000
a year and love life and
so many people I know
that have 40 million in
the bank and hate life.
And everybody's saying like cool
I'll take my chances, I'll be 40 million.
I get it but guess what?
That's what the 40 million
person's saying too.
Like damn I wish I wasn't
born into this trust fund.
People aren't listening and so eventually
we're gonna start
analyzing mental happiness.
- [Cece] Right.
- And everything is gonna start changing
and the reason I talk
about materialistic things,
it is the band-aid and the
makeup of unhappiness for 95%.
The other 5% just
genuinely have the money.
Loving, like love camouflage,
love that designer.
And they're a very artistic person, cool.
But, man, stuff,
stuff is makeup and
band-aids for unhappiness.
(cheering)
Thank you, my man.
- GaryVee, man.
- My guy!
- My guy, thank you so much for having me.
- [Cruz] My guy, my guy.
- You're my guy.
- My guy!
- Yes, my guy.
- Listen, my guy.
- Yes sir.
- You're my guy, my guy.
- And you're my guy, my guy.
- My guy, my guy.
- My guy.
- There it is, GaryVee
in the building, yes!
(clapping)
- You're welcome!
- Just so you know, Gary,
this is the most quiet we've ever been
because we're actually listening
and absorbing everything you're saying
which is good.
- I'm flattered.
- Very smart.
- I'm flattered, I'm flattered.
- [Cruz] Gary, I started four businesses
in the middle of that interview.
(group laughs)
- In your head, right?
The biggest part is the mindset
that it takes to do that.
- Absolutely.
- Right, because, you know,
the biggest thing I'm worried
about is all these people
that are starting businesses
that are gonna fail
and then are gonna be sad
and pretend they didn't fail
because they don't want the judgment.
- Right, right, right.
- [Man] They're more concerned
about what their friends
and relatives thinks about them.
- Well are you concerned
abut failing or judgment?
You know what I mean, fuck judgment.
You know because you could recover
- Failing, I love losing.
I love the humbleness.
- Well there's a lesson in it, you know?
- I'll give you a good one, just happened.
That same piece of content with that woman
I was like yo this could have been bigger.
Let's repackage it, I'm talking to DRock.
Like yo this is how
we're gonna package it.
We put it out yesterday, it did worse.
And I texted him and I
was like this is the best.
I love for all that I think that
I get this better than
anybody, punched in the mouth.
And I'm like I love it.
- That's good.
- Of course!
- GaryVee, ladies.
- Hello ladies.
- This is Briana.
- Hi Brianna, nice to
meet you, how are you?
- [Gary] Nice to meet you, how are you?
- Hi.
- [Cece] And the interns,
I don't know their names.
- [Cruz] This is the
squad, this is the squad.
- Hi, nice to meet you.
- Nice to meet you.
- Her henchmen.
- Nice to meet you guys.
- [Man] You already designed
the uniforms for the Jets?
- Not yet, my man, I don't
get ahead of myself, you know?
I'm focused on the things
I got to do to get there.
By then, you know, when I get it,
then I'll start worrying about that.
I think this is the
greatest era to be alive in
because, listen, I know
what's going on in society.
I know about all this
but here's the punchline,
this internet thing is no joke.
- [Interviewer] No joke!
- No, joke.
- [Interviewer] And it's only
evolving and getting crazier.
And blockchain, and bitcoin.
- And you're preaching and
you're being thoughtful
but making it narrow to music,
look at all the biggest
artists in the world.
Where did they come from?
SoundCloud, Spotify, a video.
Like it's different
now, it's different now.
When you can be in the
basement with a laptop
making crazy beats.
Right, you can record your song.
You don't need the
studio time the same way.
It's just so different.
So like all these kids that are,
if you're not making it now, well...
(laughing)
- [Interviewer] You definitely
wouldn't have made it
10, 20 years ago.
- You know, that's exactly right
where you had to get lucky quote, unquote
because you were playing a show.
- Gatekeepers.
- [Interviewer] I think
that's the biggest thing,
there are no more gatekeepers.
- Those A&R people,
those record executives,
those companies, they don't
have the leverage no more.
- I don't think you understand
you reach maybe more people
than you think you do, you reached me.
I've been following you
for a couple of years.
- Thank you, my friend.
- And in 2017, you did your 2017 Challenge
which just sort of made me
think a little bit more.
I said you know what, I'm gonna do it
and I did it and I was successful.
In 2018, I did it again and
I'm four times as successful.
This is on the side.
- It's crazy, right?
- So it's just one of those things
you just got to give it a shot.
- What did you start flipping first?
- Well I've been doing
investments for years
so I just said you know what
let me try some things
that I just, you know
- Know about.
- Afraid to do.
- Yeah, like?
- I'm really secure,
I'll do covered calls.
I'll do other investments.
Just things I know I've been doing
for a long time just had
to trust myself to do it.
And I think to myself
I could have been doing
it for five years before.
Could have been doing it a lot longer.
- Who cares, you're so young
at least you started now.
- Got it.
- Thank you.
- [Gary] My pleasure, take
care, guys, stay well.
Take care, thank you.
- You're welcome.
- [Photographer] Three, two, one, boom.
Boom.
- [Gary] Okay, real quick, yep.
- [Cece] Okay he'll help
you, thank you guys.
- Yo what up it's GaryVee
and I'm hanging with J Cruz,
LA's hip hop morning show.
Love it, thank you my guy, take care.
Alright, alright.
One sec, hold on, Tyler, hold on.
- Just a little motivational
for my followers?
- Sure.
- Yo what up everybody, it's GaryVee.
We're just hanging here.
- Hi.
- Listen, one life, do something about it
and stop having entitlement,
nobody owes you shit.
Go get yours.
- That's right, thanks.
- You're welcome, take care.
- Thank you, bye.
- Yes Marty, that is what I'm saying.
Brands, when they think about big media,
just care about scale, right?
They're just like we just need reach.
They don't give a fuck about context.
Then all of a sudden when
it gets to an influencer
they're like ah she's off-brand.
Like so you're spending 40 million
on dog shit for reach
and then you're over scrutinizing $2,000
because she's off brand,
are you fucking kidding me?
(Gary scoffs)
It's crazy, it's, listen,
and I'm gonna say this respectfully,
and there's a ton of smart people here.
At the macro, it's a bizarro world
in corporate America marketing in 2018.
(gentle music)